The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
Welcome to
Underactuated Robotics.
I'm glad you're all here.
Can I get a quick show
of hands, actually,
who considers themselves
hardcore robotics types?
Don't be shy.
It's a good thing to do.
Who's here to see what
this is all about?
OK.
Good, good.
So I've thought of
course twice before.
This is the first time that
it's a TQE course for Area 2.
So I'm hoping to excite a
slightly more general audience.
And your
responsibility, then, is
to ask me questions
if I say things
that if I assume prior
knowledge that people
don't have and make sure that
everything is coming across.
The only real prereqs that
I assume for the course
are basically some comfort
with differential equations
and Ordinary Differential
Equations, ODEs.
I assume some comfort
with linear algebra.
And we use a lot of MATLAB, so
it helps if you know MATLAB.
What I don't assume
is that you're--
I mean, it's great if you
have taken previous robotics
courses.
That's certainly a good thing.
But I'm not going
to assume everybody
knows how to crank
out the kinematics
or dynamics of rigid
body manipulators
and things like that.
So hopefully, if you've
got a background in here,
then everything
else should follow.
And the course has got
a set of course notes
that will be published
on the website
just after the lectures.
And they should be
pretty much contain
what you need to know,
or at least have links
to the things you need to know.
OK.
So today is the warm-up.
I want to start with
some motivation.
I want to make sure
everybody leaves
understanding the title of
the course, if nothing else.
So I want to tell you
some motivation why
I think underactuated
robotics is such
an important topic in robotics.
I'm going to give you some
basic definitions, including
the definition of underactuated.
I'm going to go
through an example
with working out the equations
of motion for a simple system
to a review of dynamics.
And then I'm going
to tell you quickly,
in the last minutes,
everything else you're
going to learn in the course.
And then we'll go through that
more slowly in the next 25
lectures.
OK.
So let me actually start
with some motivation.
That involves
plugging in this guy.
OK.
How many people have
seen ASIMO before?
Good.
OK.
So ASIMO-- let's watch the
little promotional video
for Honda's ASIMO.
This is a few years old now.
But ASIMO absolutely
is the pinnacle
of robotics engineering over the
last 20 years, I'd say, even.
So Honda, turns out,
without telling anybody,
was working on walking
robots from the early '80s
till they announced
to the world in 1997
that they'd started building
these walking robots.
And they started
putting on these shows
where they'd kick soccer
balls and walk up stairs.
It's absolutely,
absolutely amazing.
I mean, this is it.
This is what we've been
waiting for in robotics
for a very long time.
This is a humanoid
robot absolutely doing
fantastic things.
It's a marvel of engineering.
The precision, the amount of
computation going on in there--
it's something we've been
waiting a long time for.
OK.
But let's watch it again and
be a little more critical
this time.
So what's wrong with
ASIMO when it's walking?
OK, it looks a little stiff.
It looks like a guy
in a space suit.
If you look carefully,
you'll notice
that it's always got one
foot flat on the ground.
That doesn't look quite right.
OK, well, we'll
forgive the goalie.
He's work in progress, I guess.
But the whole thing
just looks a little bit
like a machine
that's, let me say,
not comfortable with
its own dynamics.
It's taking a very
conservative approach.
The fact that it can go
upstairs is really remarkable.
It does have to know exactly
where those stairs are
and the geometry of the stairs.
But you see, it's taking a
very, very conservative approach
to walking.
It's always walking
with its knees bent,
its feet flat on the ground,
and has this rigid astronaut
walk to it.
OK.
Why is that bad?
It's bad because it requires
a lot of energy, first of all.
So just imagine walking
around with your knees bent
all the time.
It turns out, ASIMO uses
20 times as much energy
if you scale out
mass and everything
as a human does when it walks--
20 times.
And that makes a
practical difference
because the batteries
it's got in its belly
only last 26 minutes, and
it's a lot of batteries.
It matters because
it's walking--
because of this very
conservative approach
to walking, it's walking a lot
slower than you or I would.
They actually have top
running speeds of ASIMO.
They're six kilometers an hour.
But that's a little
bit below where
you are I would sort of
comfortably transition
from walking to running
if we were just going down
the street.
So it's considerably slower
than a human when it runs.
And although there's some
really amazing videos
of walking on stairs
and things like that,
the videos you won't
see are the ones
of it walking on terrain
it doesn't know everything
about or even uneven terrain.
It doesn't do even
train particularly well.
OK.
So in some ways, ASIMO is
the very natural progression
of what robotic arm
technology, which
started in factory room floors,
matured into a walking robot.
OK.
It's a very high-gain--
we'll talk a lot
about what that means.
It's a very high-gain system.
It's using a lot of
energy and feedback
in order to try to rigidly
follow some trajectory
that it's thought a lot about.
And it's doing that in a very
conservative regime-- feet
flat on the ground, knees bent.
So there's a different
approach to walking out there.
This one was built by Cornell.
It's called a passive
dynamic walker.
It's almost not a
robot whatsoever.
It's a bunch of sticks and
hinges with ball bearings
at the joints.
But if you put this thing
on a small ramp going down
and give it a little
push, look what it can do.
That's just falling
down a ramp--
completely passive machine
powered only by gravity.
So these passive walkers
are a fantastic demo.
I mean, it's unbelievable
that they can
build these things that walk.
It's a glorified slinky.
But it's walking like
you and me, right?
Probably more so.
Most people would say that looks
a little bit more like the way
we walk than ASIMO does.
But what's really
amazing about it
is it says that this really
conservative, high-gain, feet
flat on the ground
approach to walking,
it's certainly not
a necessary one.
And it suggests
that if you really
want to do some energy-efficient
walking, maybe even
more robust walking,
then what you need to do
is not cancel out your dynamics
with high-gain feedback
and follow some trajectory.
You need to think a lot about
the dynamics of your robot.
So this is just the dynamics of
the robot doing all the work--
no control system, no
computers, nothing.
OK.
So that's a story
in talking about why
maybe dynamics matter a lot.
And we should really start
by understanding the dynamics
before we do a whole bunch
of robotic arm control.
It's actually true in a
lot of different fields.
My other favorite story
these days is flying things.
So if you look at
state-of-the-art military
aircraft, this is an F-14
landing on an aircraft carrier.
Even in the most highly
engineered control systems
we have, it tends to be that
aircraft stay in a very, very
conservative flight envelope.
The same way that ASIMO
stays with its feet
flat on the ground and does
this really stiff control,
the airplane stays at a very low
angle relative to the oncoming
flow and uses high-gain control
in order to stabilize it.
So fighter jets-- you might
know, the patent fighter
jets tend to be passively
unstable, and control systems
are doing amazing things
to make these guys work.
But they're not doing
some basic things
that you can see every time
you look out your window.
So here's a cardinal doing
sort of the same thing--
landing on an aircraft
carrier, landing on a branch--
about the same thing.
But unlike the
airplane, the cardinal's
got his wings spread
out way out to here.
And what that means, if you know
anything about aerodynamics,
if you take a wing and the
airflow is moving this way,
and you have it at a low angle
relative to the oncoming flow,
then you have a very
simple attached flow
on the back of the wings.
And it turns out that linear
control and linear models
of the dynamics work
pretty well in that regime.
If you go up to a
small angle of attack,
like the fighter jet's
doing, then the air
can bend around the wing.
Everything still stays
attached, they say, to the wing.
And you can still do
linear control ideas.
OK.
But if you go up and
stall your wings out--
that's what's happening here.
If you go up to a
higher angle of attack,
the air can no longer bend
around the wing fast enough.
Something more dramatic happens.
You get a big vortex
in this picture.
And what happens is the flow
gets much more unsteady.
It starts shedding vortices.
And you start
stalling your wing.
Now in these regimes
so far, the dynamics
have proven very,
very complicated
to even understand, even
model, and considerably harder
to control.
The birds doing it
every day of the week.
Somehow, we don't
know exactly how,
but he does it all the time.
And he does it with
gusty environments.
He does it when the
branch is moving.
He probably misses
every once in a while.
But he's doing a
pretty darn good job.
There's a reason why
he does it too, right?
It's not just to show
off or something.
But if you are willing to go
into this more complicated
flight regime by
stalling your wings,
and if your goal is
stopping, then, actually, you
get a huge benefit by going up
to that high angle of attack.
Not only do you get more
drag just because you
have more surface area
exposed to the flow,
but when you start
getting separation
on the back of
your wing you leave
a pocket of low pressure
behind the wing.
The air can't quite come
in and fill in the space
right behind the wing.
And that acts like an air brake.
It's called pressure drag.
So the birds-- the
planes are coming
into this conservative
approach in order
to maintain control authority.
The birds are going [GRUNTS],,
hitting the air brakes
and coming to still somehow
doing enough control
to hit that perch, which is
kinematically more difficult,
I think, than even hitting
an aircraft carrier.
All right.
So In my group,
we've been working
on trying to make planes
do that kind of thing.
So this is our airplane
that comes in and tries
to execute a very high
angle of attack maneuver
in order to land on a perch.
It's a slow-motion
shot, slowed down
so you can see what happens.
And actually, just to
convince you that the flow
is complicated.
This isn't our best
flow of visualization,
but it shows you
what's going on here.
The airflow, as
it comes in, this
is now that same plane with--
we're emitting smoke from the
front of the wing, the leading
edge of the wing.
And it comes in at a
low angle of attack.
And you can see
the air is mostly--
it's actually already stalled
because it's a flat plate.
But the air is on top of
the wing in the same way I
showed you in that picture.
And as you go up to a
high angle of attack,
you get this big tip
vortex that rolls over.
Everything gets a
lot more complicated.
So the point I'm trying to make
with these two examples are
first of all, robots
today are just really,
really conservative.
Dynamically, they're
very, very conservative.
They're operating
just a fraction
of the level of performance
that they should already
expect given the same
mechanical design.
With the same mechanical
design, a simple little plane
but better control, we
can start doing things
that look more like birds.
And the second point that I'm
going to make more formally
in a minute is that the
underactuated systems,
underactuated robotics
is essentially
the art, the science of
trying to build machines which
use their dynamics more
cleverly instead of trying
to build control systems
which use actuation motor
output in order to
override the dynamics.
We're going to do an
underactuated system that just
pushes and pulls the
natural dynamics,
tries to do these more
exciting dynamic things.
As a consequence, we need
to do smarter control.
This is a computer
science course.
So what have I said anything to
do with computer science yet?
I believe that there's new
techniques from computer
science, machine learning,
motion planning that are
basically changing the game.
It's allowing us to solve
some of these control problems
that haven't been solved before.
Just to throw a few
more cool examples out--
so if more willing to
do more clever things
with our dynamics, then
there's just countless things
that we can do.
So if you just care
about efficiency--
this is a wandering albatross.
If you just measure the energy
in some metabolic estimate
of the energy it consumes
versus the distance it travels,
then it's about the same as
a 747, which is actually cool
because they're quite
different sizes.
But if you just do some
dimensional cost of transport,
it actually works out to be
almost the same efficiency
as a 747.
So maybe we haven't
gained anything.
But it turns out if you
look more carefully,
the albatross uses the
same amount of energy
when it's sitting on the
beach as it does when
it's flying across the ocean.
So this guy can
fly for hours, days
without ever flapping its wings.
Go across the entire ocean
that way, into the wind,
out of the wind-- you name it--
because they're sitting there
and they're just riding on
gradients due to the
wind over the ocean.
So the energetic cost
this guy's experiencing
is just digestion
and things like that.
He's actually not doing hardly
any mechanical work in order
to fly across the ocean.
OK.
If you care about
maneuverability,
you know, so falcons have
been recently clocked diving
at 240 miles an hour.
This one is pulling out of that
240-mile-an-hour dive to catch
a sparrow.
That's pretty good.
I mean, planes-- in
terms of sheer speed,
planes are going to win
every day of the week.
But if you look at some
sort of dimensionless aspect
of maneuverability,
then birds are still
the masters of the sky.
Bats can actually be flying full
speed this way in two flaps,
which turns out to be just
under half of the wingspan,
they can be flying
full-speed the other way--
two to five flaps.
This guy's at Brown have
been recording this.
Obviously, bats are actually
some of the most maneuverable.
They can fly at high speeds
through thick rain forests.
They can fly in caves with
1,000 other bats on top of them.
At least, that's what I
get out of the movies.
[LAUGHTER] And they're doing
all these just incredibly
dynamic things in ways that
our control systems can't even
come close to right now.
And this is one of my
favorite videos of all time.
Again, the story
about efficiency.
This is a fish now, not a bird.
But it's almost the same thing.
They're both
operating in a fluid.
This is a rainbow trout.
So the rainbow trout
are the fish that
swim upstream at mating season.
So every year, they make
their march up the streams.
It turns out if you watch
these rainbow trout,
they tend to hang
out behind rocks.
Someone thought,
it seems like it's
tiring work going upstream maybe
there's something clever going
on when they're hanging
out behind these rocks.
So what they did is they
took that rainbow trout out,
and they put it
in a water tunnel.
And you're looking
at a view from above
of the fish swimming
in the water tunnel.
This is George Lauder's
lab at Harvard.
And that's what it looks
like when it's just
swimming in open water.
If you take that same fish,
put it in the water tunnel
but put a rock in front of it--
now if you've looked at rocks
in a river, behind a rock,
you'll get some swirling
vortices, some eddies.
The fish behind the
rock just completely
changes the kinematics
of its gait.
So that's suggestive
that there's
something clever going on here.
But this is the clincher here.
The dynamics matter
if you're a fish.
This is now a dead fish.
It's a dead fish.
There's a piece of string making
sure it doesn't go back and get
caught in the grates.
That would be messy.
But it's slack.
As it's moving
around, you'll see
when the string is catching.
This is our rock now.
It's a half cylinder.
The water's going this way.
There's going to be
swirling vortices
off the back of that rock.
Let's see what
happens if you put
a dead fish behind the rock.
So the vortices are
knocking the fish around.
That's not too surprising.
What's really cool
is when the dead fish
starts swimming upstream.
That's pretty good.
So the water's going that
way, and the fish just
went that way.
And it's dead.
So dynamics matter
if you're a fish.
And if you care about birds--
mechanically, we're capable
now of building robotic birds.
This is our best copy
of a hobby ornithopter.
But we can build
birds that fly around
with Derek at the controls.
But if you asked me how
to control this bird
to make it land on a perch,
pull energy out of the air,
we haven't got a clue.
We're working on it.
We haven't got a clue.
Yeah, that hit a tree.
And Derek recovered.
We've got the first flight
of our big 2-meter wingspan.
This is an autonomous flight.
You can tell it's autonomous
because it flies straight
into it about runs
into the building
and then we hit the
brakes, and it has
to go in and hit the trash can.
But mechanically,
we're close to where
we want to be to replicate
some of nature's machines.
We've got a long way to go.
But really, we're
at the point where
we have to figure
out how to take
these magnificent dynamical
machines and control them.
And that's what the
course is about.
OK.
So let's get a little
bit more careful in what
I mean by underactuated.
Systems.
So we'll give you
some motivation.
We're going to try to make
robots that run like humans--
run like gazelles,
swim like dead fish,
and fly like that falcon
that comes down-- so not
a tall order at all, right?
So in order to start
doing that, let's start
by just defining what it
means to be underactuated.
Let me ground things
in an example.
Let's take a
two-link robotic arm.
I'm going to describe the
state of this system with theta
1 and a relative
angle here, theta 2.
And let me quickly
draw that twice as big.
We'll parameterize
it here with the--
that'll be L1 with the length.
This will be able L2 here.
So we call this mass 1, mass 2.
So we'll assume it's a
massless rod with a point
mass at the end, just to keep
the equations a little cleaner
for today.
And it's got two angles
that I care about.
And there's a couple
lengths at play.
So throughout the
class, I'm going
to use the convention that q
is a vector of the joint angles
or the coordinates of the robot.
In this case, it's going
to be theta 1 and theta 2.
If I have motors
on the robot, let's
say, I can apply a
torque here because I
have a motor at the elbow,
maybe a torque here.
So I'll call this
torque 1, this torque 2.
I'm going to call
that u, vector u.
There's all the
inputs to the system.
So this is the
joint coordinates.
These are the control inputs.
OK.
So it turns out if
you want to write out
the dynamics of
this system, if you
want to be able
to, say, simulate
the way that this
pendulum moves, well, most
of the robots we care
about in this class are
our second-order.
So everything's based on
their mechanical system.
So we've got F equals
ma governing everything.
In this case, a is going to
be the second derivative of q.
So what I really have--
I should also say
that q-dot is going
to be the joint velocities.
And q-double-dot is the
joint accelerations.
So if I want to describe
the motion of these systems,
of this kind of a
robot, then what I need
is to find an
equation that tells me
the acceleration of
that system based
on the current position,
velocity of the robot,
and the current control inputs.
If we're living in second-order
mechanical systems world,
then that means I'm looking
for a governing equation--
equations of motion
of the form f
is some nonlinear function of q,
q-dot, u, potentially time too,
if it's a time-varying dynamics,
if there's something else going
on clocked by time.
So basically, the
entire class, we're
going to be looking at
second-order systems governed
by some non-linear
equations like them.
It turns out that actually most
of the robots we care about,
there's even a simpler form.
Turns out we can
almost always find--
it's not always--
but for many robots,
we find that the
equations of motion
are actually linear in u.
If I'm going to put in torques
or something to my robot,
that it turns out that the
way that the torques affect
accelerations is
linear in the input.
So let me write a
second form, which takes
advantage of that observation.
OK.
So I've said almost
nothing here.
I'm just saying
there's some nonlinear
terms that depend on the current
state, and velocity, and time.
There's some other nonlinear
terms that get multiplied by u.
But the only power
in this is that I'm
saying that the whole
thing is linear in u.
And it turns out to be--
I'll convince you as we go
forward that that's true.
OK.
So here's our-- we're finally
grounding everything here.
Let me tell you what
fully actuated means.
Just think about what
this equation is too.
So q is a vector.
Q-double-dot is also a vector.
In this case, q was
a 2 by 1 vector.
Q-dot then is also
Q-double-dot is also
a 2 by 1 vector.
So this is a vector equation of
a 2 by 1 vector in this case.
This is some vector--
2 by 1 vector.
In my case, I had also
two control inputs.
So this is also a 2 by
1 vector, which means
what is this thing going to be?
That's going to be a 2 by
2 matrix in that example.
What matters, what makes
life dramatically easier,
and what most robots
today have really assumed
is that they assume
that F2 is full rank.
So a robot of this form is fully
actuated if the rank of F2, q,
q-dot, and time is equal--
I'll write the
dimension of q here--
its full rank.
OK.
Why does that matter?
What does that mean first?
What it means is that
if I know F1 and F2,
then I can use u to do anything
I want to q-double-dot.
OK.
I'll show you that.
I can say that right
now pretty explicitly.
So let's say I know
exactly what F1 and F2 are.
Let's say I choose
a control law.
I want to choose u
as some function--
I'll just call it pi--
of q, q-dot, and time.
So I want to come up
with a controller which
looks at my positions, and
my velocities, what time it
is, and comes up with a torque.
Let's say, I did F2
inverse q, q-dot, and time
times negative F1, q, q-dot,
time plus, I don't know,
some other controller, but I
want u-prime, let's call it.
So if the rank of F2--
if it's full rank, if
it's got the same rank
as the dimension of
q, then that means
that this F2 inverse exists.
And I think that if
you plug this in for u
right there, what
you're going to see
is that this cancels out this.
If I did it right, then,
and this cancels out this.
And what I'm left with
is a simple system now.
Q-double-dot equals u-prime.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't that be
q-double-dot [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Where do
you want q-double-dot?
AUDIENCE: Is that u?
RUSS TEDRAKE: This is u-prime.
So just some other u.
So what I'm trying
to do is now say
that I'm going to
effectively change
the equations of motion of
my system into this, u-prime.
I might have called that
maybe q-double-dot desired
or something like that.
That would be fine too.
So what did we just do?
We did a trick called
feedback linearization.
I took what was potentially
a very complicated nonlinear
equations of motion,
and because I
could, using my control input,
command every q-double-dot,
I can essentially effectively
replace the equations of motion
with a simpler equation.
This is actually a
trivially simple equation.
For those of you
that know, this is
what would be a series of single
inputs, single outputs systems.
They're decoupled.
So q-double-dot 1 is equal
to the first element of this.
It's just two vectors.
So that just looks like a trick.
I'm going to ground it in
an example in a second here.
But first, let's finish defining
what underactuated means.
So what is underactuated
going to mean?
AUDIENCE: That the other
two matrices is important.
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's right.
Good.
Yeah, a system of that
form is underactuated
if the rank of F2,
q, q-dot, and time is
less than the dimension of q.
In words, what
underactuated means--
a system is under actuated
if the control input cannot
accelerate the system
in every direction.
That's what this equation says.
If the control input
u cannot produce.
That's just what
the equation said.
You could imagine if the
form of the equations
wasn't linear in
u, then we'd have
to adapt this rank
condition to do this.
But this, I think, for today is
a very good working definition
of underactuated.
And we'll improve it as
we go through the class.
There's a couple of
things to note about it.
First of all, as
I've defined it here,
whether you're
underactuated or not
actually depends on your state.
So you could say that
a robot was fully
actuated in some states and
underactuated in other states.
Now why would that happen?
Maybe there's a torque
limit, or there's
an obstacle or something
like this that prevents you
from producing
accelerations when
you're in some configurations.
Intuitively, what's
happening in ASIMO
is that it's trying to stay in
this very conservative regime
because then those are
the states where it can
act like it's fully actuated.
And if it was running like you
or me, then it's underactuated.
But what I want
to try to impress
on you is that this
dichotomy between fully
actuated and underactuated
systems, it's pervasive.
I mean, so robotics, for the
last 30-some, easily, years,
has almost completely
made this assumption
that F2 is full rank when
designing controllers.
If you learn about
adaptive control,
all these manipulated
control ideas,
computer torque methods--
all these things--
you're implicitly
making this assumption
that you can produce
arbitrary torques.
You can use arbitrary
control effort
to produce arbitrary
accelerations.
What that does, that's
why all these proofs
exist for adaptive
control and the like
because you can then
effectively turn
your system into a
linear system that we
know how to think about.
And the reason that
dichotomy is so strong
is because what happens if
you're a control designer
and you don't have the ability
to take your nonlinear system
and turn it into
a linear system is
that you have no choice
but to start reasoning
about the nonlinear dynamics
of your system, reasoning
about the long-term nonlinear
dynamics of the system.
And analytics break
down pretty quick.
But computers can help.
That's why we're revisiting
this kind of idea.
So factory room
robotic arms tend
to be fully actuated, except
for very exceptional cases.
Walking robots and things
like that, as we'll see,
are underactuated.
So let's do that example.
AUDIENCE: So are you
implying that in order
to have agile robots, we need
to have underactuated robotics?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Absolutely.
I'm going to finish making
that argument, but absolutely.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
The question was, am
I implying that we
need to do underactuated
robotics to have agile robots?
Yeah.
I would even say
that I'm implying--
I'm a little biased--
but I'm implying
that every interesting
problem in robotics
is interesting because
it's underactuated.
If you think about the problems
that are unsolved in robotics--
maybe manipulation, walking,
cool flying things--
if you look closely,
if the control
problem is considered unsolved,
it's probably underactuated.
The things we know how
to do really well--
picking and placing parts
on a factory room floor--
that's fully actuated.
Now manipulation is hard
for many other reasons.
You have to find the
thing you're manipulating.
You have to think about it.
But there's
something fundamental
in robotics research
that happens
if your system suddenly-- if
you don't have complete control
authority.
And all the interesting
problems that are left
seem to be underactuated.
OK.
So instead of talking
about abstract F's, let's
make it specific.
Let's write the
equations of motion
for our two-link robotic arm.
So how many people have
seen Lagrangian mechanics?
Cool.
So the class isn't
going to depend on it.
I'm going to do
it once, quickly.
And it's in the notes.
If you haven't seen
Lagrangian mechanics,
it's a good thing to know.
And it's in the appendix
of the course notes.
It'll be posted.
But I want you to see
it once to just see
that there is actually-- if what
you care about first is just
coming up with the
equations of motion, then
there's actually a fairly
procedural way to do
that for even pretty
complicated systems.
So let's do it for this
not-very-complicated system.
OK.
So let me do that in pieces.
So let's say, this is mass 1.
Let's say that it's
that position x,1.
If I call this x,1 and x,2--
x and y-- that makes them
a coordinate system there.
Let's say that the
mass here is that x,1,
and the mass 2 is x,2.
So the first thing to do is just
to think about the kinematics
of the robot.
And in this case,
they're pretty simple.
So as I've written it, x,1 is--
what is it?
The x position in x,1 here
is l times sine or cosine?
Sine of theta 1.
And the other one is
negative L1 cosine theta 1.
Now we're going to
get bored real quick
if I don't adopt a shorthand.
So let me just
call that l,1, s,1.
So that'll be shorthand
for sine of theta 1.
And this will be
negative l,1 cosine, 1.
If I want to do the
kinematics of x,2 here,
that's going to
depend on theta 2.
It's actually also going
to depend on theta 1
because I've got this
in a relative frame.
That theta 2 is relative
to the first link.
So it turns out the
kinematics of x,2,
we can actually
start with just x,1.
It's the position of
x,1 plus another vector,
which is l,2 sine of
theta 1 plus theta 2.
If you work it out,
that's the right thing--
cosine theta 1 plus theta 2,
which are shorthand as x,1 plus
l,2 s,1 plus 2 negative
l,2 c,1 plus 2.
OK.
So the derivatives
aren't too bad.
I can do those.
Let's see.
If I want the rate
of change of x1,
intuitively, that's
going to start depending
on the joint velocities, right?
So how does that work out?
The time derivative of x,1 is
going to be l,1 cosine theta 1
times theta 1 dot.
And then l,1 sine theta
1 times theta 1 dot.
And x,2 dot is going to be x,1
dot plus l,2 c,1 plus 2 times
theta 1 dot plus theta 2 dot.
And l,2 s,1 plus 2 theta
1 dot plus theta 2 dot.
So we now have solved the
kinematics of the machine.
To write the dynamics
Lagrangian style
we need to think about
the energy of the system.
So let's call T the
total kinetic energy.
And in this case,
it's pretty simple.
This is why I went
with point masses.
It's 1/2 mv squared,
which in vector form,
looks like 1/2x 1 dot transpose
m,1 x,1 dot plus 1/2 x,2 dot
transpose m,2 x,2 dot.
OK.
And then we're going to define
the total potential energy
as u.
And this it's just mg times the
vertical position of the thing.
So it's just mass 1 times
gravity times I'll call it--
I guess I'll just call it y,1,
which is the second element
of that.
I want to even not
introduce new symbol.
We'll just do l,1 c,1 negative.
And this is minus m,2 g, y,2,
which is l,1 c,1 plus l,2 c,1
plus 2.
Sorry for going into the corner.
OK.
But you can all write the
kinetic and potential energy
of the system.
So Lagrangian derivations
of the equations of motion
just uses this Lagrangian,
which is the difference
in the kinetic minus potential.
And I think a very good exercise
is to understand the reason why
this works.
But for our class, we can
actually just use it as a crank
that we can turn.
If we write this out, and then
you do some simple math on it,
where this is called
a generalized force,
it turns out if you plug
these in to this equation,
turn your calculus
crank, then you end up
with the equations of motion.
You end up with two equations
that have the form--
they give you some equations
in terms of F, q, q-dot,
q-double-dot, it's
some function of q,
and this is actually
where the u's come in.
So in the simplest form,
it comes up like this.
And with a little
work, let the call
that F-Lagrangian so it's not
the same F. With a little work,
you can separate out
the q-double-dots
and get it to the
vector equations
we were talking about before.
OK.
If you take those equations
that you get and you pop them
into MATLAB, and
it's pretty simple
to start simulating
the equations of motion
of the two-link arm.
This is with zero control input.
So this is just what happens
if you take some two-link arm,
apply no torque, let it go.
Then you get this.
I put some damping in
there extra so we didn't
have a demonstration of chaos.
But there's a pretty
procedural way
to go from very
simple kinematics,
doing some pretty simple
energy calculations,
and getting yourself to
a simulation of even very
complicated mechanical systems.
So the forward
dynamics, we understand.
Now it turns out, there's
actually very good algorithms
for this too.
If you have a 100-link
robot, you certainly
wouldn't want to turn
the crank by hand.
But you can download
good software packages
that write recursive versions
of this algorithm that
have very efficient
computation of those dynamics.
OK.
Now let's start thinking
about what it means
to have control in that system.
It turns out, if you enough of
these equations, if you punch
in enough different robotic
arms and walking robots
or whatever-- oh, John yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think
maybe minus 3L/3q.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, OK.
Good catch.
OK.
So if you start punching
these equations enough,
then and then you start
noticing a pattern.
Turns out, even very
complicated robotic arms
tend to have equations that
fall into this stereotyped form.
OK.
This is almost just f equals ma.
This is the mass matrix,
the inertial matrix.
The c here is the
Coriolis terms.
The g here is the
gravitational terms--
potential terms.
And then this is the torques.
These are called the
manipulator equations.
We're going to revisit them.
You don't have to have complete
intuition about them right now.
But what I want
you to understand
is that if you take
the Lagrangian dynamics
on some rigid body
manipulator, then
you're going to
get something out
in a form that looks like this.
Now this is actually a
pretty powerful equation.
It tells you a lot of things.
So there's a
q-double-dot term that's
multiplied linearly by something
that only depends on q.
So by leaving q-dot
here, I've already
strengthened my form by putting
q-double-dot in linear here.
So arbitrary equations
don't fit this.
This is a pretty special
set of equations.
There's some terms
that depend on q-dot.
And then there's some potential
terms which only depend on q.
And then we have our
joint torque king
of things over here.
And in fact, there's actually
a lot of well-known structure
in these equations.
So it turns out, I
could have written
the energy of the system as 1/2
q-dot transpose H, q, q-dot.
This inertial matrix
analogous to mass
is related to the kinetic
energy of the system.
And what that means
actually, just
by thinking of it this
way, it's well-known
that H is positive definite.
It's uniformly
positive definite.
You can't have a
negative kinetic energy.
And that manifests itself
that this matrix H, which
appears all the
time, turns out to be
equivalent to its
transpose, its symmetric,
and its positive definite.
That's shorthand for
positive definite.
It's a matrix greater than zero.
And in fact, if you look at
the equations I punched in
for the robotic
arm, it's exactly
just a matter of
computing H, C, G,
and B, which is the matrix
that maps your control
inputs into joint torques.
So H is a inertial matrix.
C is Coriolis.
G is gravity.
I think B was this because
people were running out
of letters.
I don't know.
I don't know a
reason to call it B.
But in general, B could
be a function of q maybe.
But it's just some mapping
between your control inputs
in the torques that
you want to get.
OK.
So knowing that I've taken
my simple manipulator,
I found equations of
motion that take this form.
If I have torques to give--
torques at both the
elbow and the shoulder,
then it turns out for
that example, H and c
and G all just come
from the Lagrangian.
And B-- what's B going
to be in that example?
What size is it
going to be first?
AUDIENCE: 2 by 2.
RUSS TEDRAKE: 2 by 2.
And if I'm assuming that my
control inputs are exactly
the torques, then B is just
the 2 by 2 identity matrix.
Is this system fully actuated?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Why is
it fully actuated?
AUDIENCE: Because the rank of
the [INAUDIBLE] matrix is 2.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
But there's one other term
that was one other part
of that statement.
AUDIENCE: That's equal to
the dimension of q-dot.
RUSS TEDRAKE: But I
need to get the mapping
from q-double-dot u.
AUDIENCE: Oh, matrix
is positive definite.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
Because the inertial matrices
are always also positive
definite, that if I actually
write out q-double-dot that
for these systems, I get an
H inverse q times all that
stuff--
B, q, u minus C--
oh leave the q-dot G. And
we know H inverse exists.
I told you it's
positive definite.
So as long as this thing is
full rank, which as you said,
it is, then that
system's fully actuated.
OK.
That means I can do anything
I want to that system.
What should we do that system?
What should we do?
Let's replace the dynamics
with something else.
Well, I can't do anything.
It's going to have to be
two variables or less,
the system I want to simulate.
I can't make it simulate a
whip if I've only got two.
But I can make it
simulate any sort
of two-dimensional
second-order system.
OK.
How about we take our
two-link pendulum and make it
act like a one-link pendulum.
That's a simple
enough thing to do.
So what I'd do is I'd find
the equations of motion
for the one-link
pendulum, and I just
do my feedback
linearization trick.
I'd cancel it out, and
I'd replace the dynamics
with the one-link pendulum.
All right.
So if you can see this,
it's just a matter
of saying u is C times x-dot.
In my MATLAB code
and in lecture,
I'll use x to mean the
combination of q and q-dot.
I can just do my exact
feedback linear trick--
u is C plus G.
Let's see if I can make
this a little better.
And there's the equations
of a simple pendulum
with a little damping.
In my control system,
if I say, lecture1--
I think I put under simple
pend, then suddenly, my two-link
pendulum-- the dynamics
of my two-link pendulum,
when I'm simulating
those entire dynamics,
work out to be the dynamics
of my one-link pendulum.
So it's maybe not
a useful trick.
If I really wanted
a one-link pendulum,
I could have done a
one-link pendulum.
Let's say I want to do
something more clever maybe.
Let's invert gravity.
Let's take my inverted
pendulum problem
and make it work
by just replacing
the dynamics of my pendulum
with an upside-down pendulum.
So maybe if I want to just
get the pendulum to the top,
let's just make it act like
an upside-down pendulum.
So we can do that too.
Woop.
When I say it the
way I'm saying it,
I hope it sounds like, of
course, if the system's
feedback linearizable, you
can do whatever you want.
It's easy.
It's not worth thinking
about these kind of things.
I mean, that's what I'm
trying to communicate.
But almost every cool
robot that works because
of these kind of tricks.
They're hidden,
but they're there.
A lot of the reason robotic
arms work as well as they
do is because you can do this.
Now there's limits, right?
You can only do this if
you have unlimited torque.
In practice, a lot
of robotic arms
have almost unlimited
torque to give.
They've got big
gearboxes, right?
You'd be surprised how
pervasive this idea is.
So what this class
is about is what
happens if you can't do that?
All right.
So let's take our
hour two-link arm.
How are we going to break it?
How are we going to make it
so we can't do that anymore?
What's a more
interesting problem?
AUDIENCE: Get rid of one motor.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Get
rid of a motor.
Let's get rid of
the shoulder motor.
That seems like
an important one.
Let's see what happens if we
take that right out of there.
So the equations
of motion actually
stay exactly the same,
except for now, B of q
is going to have to
be smaller if u is now
just one-dimensional.
I've got a single control input.
And B of q is just
going to be what size?
AUDIENCE: 1 by 1?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's going to be--
it's got to get to a
two-dimensional thing.
So it's going to be a 2 by 1.
And let's say if as I
drew it, that 2 by 1
is going to have nothing to
do to the shoulder motor.
If I assume the first
one is the shoulder,
it's going to have direct
control of the elbow.
Suddenly, it's a
whole different game.
Turns out, you can still
solve that problem.
I wasn't thinking
of showing this.
But let me preview something
to come quickly here.
This is exactly that system.
It's a system we're
going to talk about.
It's called the Acrobot.
It's got inertia in the
links instead of the mass.
And if you take these
computer science techniques
I'm going to tell
you about, then
you can, for instance, find
a solution for the torque
at the elbow to try to make
this thing go to the top.
If you think about
it, it's actually--
it's called the Acrobot
because it's like an acrobat
on the high bar,
where you don't have--
you can only give a little
bit of torque at the wrist.
You can do a lot with
your waist, potentially.
So this, if you do
a clever job, you
can actually pump up energy and
swing up and get to the top.
But that's a lot harder problem.
And I can't write that
down in a single board here
at 72-point font.
But we're going to do
that very, very soon.
So I hope you know what
underactuated means now.
Why would I care
about a system that's
missing its shoulder motor?
That seems pretty arbitrary.
If I'm building a robot, I might
as well order enough motors
to put them everywhere.
It turns out if you care
about walking robots,
one of the simplest
models of a walking robot
is called the
compass gait robot.
It's got a mass at the hip.
It's got two legs.
We can even assume it's
got a pin joint here.
That's the connection to the--
that's the foot on the ground.
And it's got to torque
to give here at the hip.
But it can't apply
torque to the ground.
It's not because it's
not an artificial.
If I had a foot, then
suddenly, my toe--
somewhere, you're not
bolted to the ground.
So you've got a bunch
of interesting links,
and you can apply torque
between your links.
But the place where
you might want
it the most-- your
shoulder motor,
your elbow motor,
whatever it is--
the place that connects
you to the ground,
you don't have a motor.
And you can't have a
motor unless you're
willing to stick
yourself to the ground.
Suction cups are a viable thing
for walking robots, I guess.
But the more
interesting problem is
how do you do
control if you don't
have to be stuck to the ground?
So that two-link
simple point mass thing
is actually exactly the dynamics
of the compass gait walker
that we'll talk
about fairly soon.
OK so I've got no torque here.
Torque equals 0 there.
Every walking robot
is underactuated.
The same thing is true.
If I'm a humanoid,
I'm trying to control
all of my state variable.
That's the question, right?
Do I have enough motors
to instantaneously affect
every state variable?
That's the question.
If you count the number of
motors on me, it's a lot.
They might not be as
strong as they used to be.
But they're there.
There's a lot of them.
If you count the number
of degrees of freedom,
that's hard too.
But no matter what
your count, your tally
adds up to, if I jump,
when I'm up in the air--
I'm not going to
do that for you.
But when I'm up in the
air, none of those motors,
no matter what I do,
I could do something
with my arms, whatever,
ignoring aerodynamic forces.
None of those motors are
going to change the trajectory
of my center of mass.
There's nothing I can do
to change the trajectory
of my center of mass.
I can move relative
to my center mass,
change my angle of momentum.
I can serve angular momentum.
I can move things around.
But nothing I can do is
going to move my center mass.
A walking robot--
a jumping robot,
for sure, is underactuated.
A flying machine
is underactuated.
I mean, fighter jets
are a good example.
You can go that way pretty well.
You know, they don't
go backwards so well,
for instance.
All right, they don't
go directly up so well.
Although, I can show you
videos of that kind of thing.
birds-- you name it.
These systems tend to have
control variables that you're
not in complete control of.
Manipulation-- if I'm
throwing this chalk around,
I don't have complete
control of that chalk.
If I form a force
closure with it,
then you can maybe
start thinking
I'm a fully actuated system.
I can move this thing around.
That's fine.
But I think the interesting
part of manipulation
is before you get
that force closure.
OK.
So every interesting problem
in robotics is underactuated.
I'm going to give a quick sketch
of what the rest of the term
has for you.
And then we're actually--
we're going to try something
new on the website.
So the website's going
to contain everything.
After today, we're a
paperless existence.
The website will have
your problem sets.
It'll have the lecture notes.
You can submit your problems
that's on the website.
We're also going
to try a new thing.
When I post the PDFs
of the problem set,
you'll be able to download them
and print it out if you like.
But you'll also be able to use
this sort of interactive PDF
viewer where people, instead
of having a forum or something
on the website, you could
go right into the PDF
and mark, say, I don't
understand what this means.
You can choose whether
it's anonymous.
everybody knows who said it.
You can choose if
it's just private.
In just a minute, I'll
show us a demo of that.
We'll see if it works.
And it might be a cool
way to communicate
outside of the room.
But let me tell you-- let me
forecast what's coming here.
I haven't actually told you
why this is a computer science
class yet.
So I can't let you
leave without that.
Here's roughly what we're doing.
On Thursday, we're going to
talk about the simple pendulum.
So we talked about a
two-link pendulum just now.
We're going to take a step
backwards on Thursday.
We're going to talk about the
dynamics of a simple pendulum.
But we're going to
talk about everything
there is to know about
the simple pendulum.
And we're going to really think
about the nonlinear dynamics
and how to think about that.
And then we're going to
think about how to control
that simple pendulum.
But as we go in the
class, we're going
to get to more and more
interesting systems.
We're going to get to
a cart pull system.
These are some of
the model systems
in underactuated robotics.
We're going to get to
the Acrobot system I just
showed you, a two-link
thing with a torque here
and no torque there.
This one has a force here.
We're going to think
about the toy systems
for underactuated robotics.
And then we're going
to start splintering
into different domains.
If we care about
walking, then we
can start thinking about these
compass gait-type robots.
And we'll talk about
more complicated robots.
And the key difference
between here and here
is just we added a few
extra degrees of freedom.
Here to here, the
dimensionality of walking robots
isn't actually
necessarily that high.
But what happens is
you have to think
about systems with impacts.
And you have to think
about limit cycles.
We'll develop some
of those tools.
OK.
And then we're
going to think about
how do you get away
from these toy systems
by making
higher-dimensional systems?
And it can come
from walking too.
We'll have, for instance,
multi-link robots.
And think about how to control
the higher-dimensional systems,
more Degrees Of Freedom--
DOFs.
Then we're going
to think about what
happens if I take
these model systems
and add some uncertainty
or stochasticity.
So a toy example for that might
be a walking robot walking
on rough terrain, let's say.
And then we're going
to think about how
to take these model
systems and what happens
if we don't know the model.
And that's certainly the case
if you've got a little perching
airplane, for instance,
or a little robotic bird.
I have a two-year-old daughter.
And I've started being asked
to cartoon everything I say.
So I'll subject you to some
very bad but quick cartoons.
OK.
So that's the systems
we're going to think about
and the reasons that
they're interesting.
Turns out, we're going to take
a very computational approach
to them.
So in this system,
we're going to start
introducing optimal control.
We're going to say,
let's say, I want
to get the pendulum to the
top, but I want to do it,
for instance, by minimizing
energy or minimizing
the time I get there.
So we're going to talk
about optimal control.
And as much as we
can, we're going
to talk about analytical
optimal control.
But pretty quick, we're
going to run out of things
we can do analytically.
And we're going to start looking
at numerical optimal control--
computer science, again,
based on dynamic programming.
And that's going to
get us somewhere.
When we start taking these
slightly more interesting
systems like this, we're going
to develop some better tools.
We're going to do numerical
optimal control with something
called policy search, which
is a combination of tools
from reinforcement
learning, machine learning,
and numerical optimization.
We'll be able to do some
of our impact modeling
with that too, I guess.
When we start getting into
higher and higher dimensional
systems, we're going have to
give up on the opportunity
to completely solve an
optimal control problem
numerically or analytically.
And we're going to start talking
about approximate policy search
and motion planning.
And I'm drawing it
like this because I
want you to see that
we're taking a very spiral
course through the class.
We're going to develop
tools that every time I
develop a new tool, we're going
to make sure we understand what
the heck they do to the
pendulum, the cart pull,
and things like that,
and work back up.
So we're going to
cover motion planning.
If you know randomized
motion planning--
RRTs feedback motion planning--
you're going to see that here.
And then when you get
into the really good stuff
here, when you've got
uncertainty, stochasticity,
and unknown models,
then we're going
to have to get into pure
machine learning approaches
in some cases.
That looks just
like my yellow one.
Control based on reinforcement
learning, for instance.
And that's how we're
going to address
some of these systems that
are more complicated still.
OK.
So we're going to
route everything
in mechanical systems because
that's what I care about.
I want things to move.
But we're going to do it in a
pretty computer science-y way
because I think the
computer scientists have
turned a corner,
and they're going
to solve all these problems.